We are taking calls at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. Let's go next to Jagga from Chicago.
Jagga from Chicago. You're on the air.
Hello. Hello. How are you?
I'm pretty good. How are you? Good.
With Trump going to Florida and such,
supposedly when he leaves the White House, yeah,
those sort of thing. Does this sort of remind you
of, like, how the civil war started in terms
of history of him going to Florida and sort of
seceding from there in the sense of like Trump
goes Trump goes to the south and maybe generates
a rebellion from like a parallel position of
leadership down at Mar a Lago or something.
Yes, similar to how the civil war started.
I don't think so, I really don't think so.
I mean, you know, it's always like if you I'm
here's the thing that's difficult about this.
I don't know if you're familiar. Jagga
with the book Black Swans by Nassim
Nicholas Taleb. Have you heard of that book?
I have not this Nassim Taleb works with the
idea of rare events and the fundamental nature
of how it's difficult to because these Black
Swan events are so rare, there's no way to
properly account for them in our thinking.
So like a former president going to Florida and
starting the equivalent of a modern confederacy,
generating a civil war because it would be such
a black swan event, it's hard to to really take
it too seriously. So obviously, in retrospect,
we may say, oh, my God, obviously, that's what
Trump did. It was one of these black swan events.
But it does not strike me as particularly likely.
OK. And do you think that is going to
be genuine healing then? And that is
genuine healing administration.
No, probably not, I mean,
you understand that at this point you have such
a highly weaponized piece of the electorate
that I mean, we've had partizanship for a long
time. That's not new. But you you've seen Trump
ism and the sort of legitimization of some of
these propaganda right wing media outlets lead to
a really difficult situation to actually heal.
Because, listen, I mean, we may have an
inauguration day Jagga, where the news
networks are broadcasting the swearing
in of the new president. And Oleanna Newsmax
are broadcasting a Trump rally in Florida. And
don't even cover the fact that there's a new
president like we. We may actually see that.
And that's not an environment where there's
going to be any real healing to speak of.
Well, thank you for taking my call. It's
unfortunate this is the way it is, but yeah.
My pleasure. Thank you, Jäger from Chicago,
very much, appreciate hearing from you.